There are a lot of pivotal movie scenes that
really require thespians to crank up the waterworks
and send home the emotion of the moment.
So, how do these stars manage to trickle out
those tears again and again with each take?
Let's take a look at how some of Hollywood's
finest make it happen.
It may not be common, but there are some actors
who have the ability to summon up authentic
sobs by sheer force of will, and lots of practice.
Bryce Dallas Howard famously demonstrated
her natural gift for crying on command during
an interview with Conan O'Brien, shedding
tears while listening to the talk show host
tell a nonsensical story about the variety
of duct tape at Home Depot:
"Duct tape.
All kinds of duct tape.
You can get grey duct tape."
"Yeah."
"You do this incredible thing.
You give so much and you get so little in
return."
"I know."
The actress later returned to the same show
and revealed that her teary talent is far
from genetic.
"It’s technical."
"It's technical"
"It’s something that can be learned, and
taught, and you just need to give me a little
bit of money…"
"Right."
"... and I’ll give you all the secrets."
According to Howard, inducing the soft palate
lift that comes with yawning again and again
is key in helping her produce those crocodile
tears.
The actress revealed:
"You do it enough time and when you're talking
you can continue to lift it.
It triggers it, just talking about it for
me, it's like a physiological thing."
Howard also added that the biggest key to
crying on cue is making sure to stay completely
hydrated so there's plenty of H2O to spare
in her system.
Amy Adams can also turn on the sprinklers
at a moment's notice, but instead of relying
on a physical trick, the actress claims that
she uses quite a spicy memory to make the
waterworks happen.
Adams told Jimmy Fallon that her daughter
helped coax her into crying on cue by telling
her about a Sriracha plant in California that
was shuttered after neighboring residents
complained about the fumes coming from the
production facility.
"I really like Sriracha.
And, umm, I don't know if you heard, but they
were thinking of closing the… the plant."
Okay, maybe it was a put on.
But just try and name a bigger Sriracha fan,
we dare you!
Anna Faris revealed to late-night host James
Corden that she isn't the type of person who
can easily sob in real life, meaning it's
that much more difficult for her to cry on
camera.
The actress said:
"It's actually… a little bit weird.
If I ever cried in my personal life, [my mom]
would sort of come down on me, like, 'What
do you have to feel sorry for?'”
So, instead of trying to power through with
real tears, Faris relies on a device called
a tear stick.
Faris, Corden, and fellow guest Josh Jackson
each agreed to have the menthol crystal vapors
blown into their eyes to demonstrate for the
crowd, and within seconds, they were each
dripping with tears.
That's when Jackson revealed the secondary
trick to selling these fake tears on-screen:
"Now look three-quarters away and slightly
up."
"Yeah."
Nailed it.
Some actors don't have to stretch their minds
too far to work up the requisite tears for
a tough scene.
Daniel Kaluuya revealed that while filming
the stand-out "Sunken Place" scene for Jordan
Peele's Get Out, in which his character was
physically frozen in fear, he simply thought
about what it would be like to be in a similar
situation in real life.
In an “Actors on Actors” chat for Variety,
Kaluuya explained that a large part of tapping
into that headspace to cry involved recognizing
the parallels between his character's situation
and everyday scenarios, saying:
"It's just empathizing with someone that's
going through so much and has suppressed it,
kind of suppressed his guilt of a really bad
situation and shame.
And also his reluctance to face it.
He's paralyzed, he's paralyzed emotionally.
And I identified with that in all walks of
life.”
And thus, an unforgettable cinematic crying
scene was born.
"Now you're in the sunken place."
Empathy is a valuable trait and certainly
helpful in crying on cue, but if an actor
has his or her own harrowing life experience
to help bring the sad sobs to the set, it's
even better.
For one of his first films after his Harry
Potter days, Daniel Radcliffe starred as the
beat poet Allen Ginsberg in the biographical
drama-thriller Kill Your Darlings.
The role required Radcliffe to shed a lot
of tears, something that wasn’t exactly
easy for the actor to do.
Radcliffe told the Vancouver Sun:
"Unless you have that trick of being able
to cry on cue, which some people can do, the
more you try to force it, the more awkward
and awful it becomes… as I have found!"
Unfortunately, there’s no magic spell to
summon tears.
However, Radcliffe revealed that he revisited
a helpful pointer from Gary Oldman to help
him turn on the waterworks.
The actor said his former on-screen godfather
once told him:
"Don't be afraid to use all your own stuff
because they're only going to see it happening
to the character."
"You weren't gonna tell me?"
"We both know why you can't come."
Radcliffe didn't share what memory did the
trick exactly, but revealed that he did find
some success with it, saying:
"Three uncontrollable, breaking-down scenes
later… there were these real, raw tears.
The first time that happens to you on a set
full of people… even if you go in just as
that character, at that moment, it is just
you.”
Now, that’s a magical moment if we’ve
ever heard one.
Without a built-in trick or handy dandy device
to help bring on the waterworks, some actors
just have to jump into an emotional scene
feet first and hope their eyes catch up somewhere
along the way.
Oscar winner Jennifer Lawrence revealed that
for one of her big crying scenes, she actually
went through the bodily motions of mourning,
and the tears happened to follow suit.
The actress told MTV News:
"I can definitely start [sobbing] and water
comes, sometimes.
I don't have anything in my life that can
instantly make me cry.
It's mostly just the standard, hold your eyes
open, fake your way through it."
Lawrence later elaborated that she needs to
widen her eyes for a "long time" to make her
method work, but that it’s still her go-to
for the gushy scenes.
Considering how stacked her trophy shelf is
right about now, whatever she's doing is obviously
working just fine.
Will Smith might have no trouble serving up
serious drama now that he's such a seasoned
film star, but back in his earliest days on
The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air, Smith was still
learning how to emote on camera.
His starring sitcom role almost always relied
on his skill for being suave and self-assured,
but there was one important moment in the
show's fourth season that required the actor
to really dig deep.
In the poignant episode, Will's father returns
to his life and gives the teen hope that he
might finally forge a bond with the man who's
been M.I.A. throughout his upbringing.
However, he doesn’t stick around for long,
and Will delivers a heartbreaking monologue
that vacillates between contempt, determination,
and a lot of hurt.
"How come he don’t want me, man?"
Without a strong delivery by Smith, the scene
might've been hokey, but he sold his sadness
thanks to the help of his on-screen uncle,
James Avery.
Smith revealed:
"James Avery was relentlessly on me to elevate.
He was like, 'You have this position, look
where you are, look what you are blessed with.'
He was like, 'I'm sorry but I'm not accepting
anything other than absolute committed perfection
from you.'"
Hollywood history is filled with stories of
filmmakers using near-torturous techniques
to elicit an emotional response from their
stars, like when Alfred Hitchcock tormented
Tippi Hedren on the set of The Birds to capture
real fear or when Stanley Kubrick made Shelley
Duvall unwell with his harsh demands on the
set of The Shining, and her condition conveniently
aligned with her character's.
"I'm very confused…
I just need a chance to think things over."
Similarly, there have been several noteworthy
cases of cast members being coerced into crying
on-set by some of their co-workers, whether
they liked it or not.
For example, when he was still a child star,
Jackie Cooper was bullied by director Norman
Taurog into bringing it with his tears in
Skippy.
Though the role earned the then-nine-year-old
an Oscar nomination, it’s safe to say that
Taurog’s threat to kill Cooper’s dog if
the actor didn’t cry took things a bit too
far.
Similarly, Francis Ford Coppola reportedly
resorted to calling Winona Ryder vicious names
to bring her to tears on the set of Bram Stoker's
Dracula.
There are some actors so talented that they
simply don’t have a need to turn to methods
or manufacturing when they’re called to
be emotionally affected in a scene.
In a surprise to no one, Meryl Streep, largely
considered the greatest actress of our time,
is one of those skilled few.
In a discussion with the students at the University
of Texas, Streep revealed that her process
is simply to power through whatever challenge
she faces, including bringing tears to the
table even when she isn't actually in the
mopey mood.
The actress said:
"The hardest thing to do is to do something
when you don't feel it.
It's weird and hard to do what isn't really
happening and make it like it is.
But we need actors.
We need them to help us understand different
emotions and realities.
To console us.
To let us know that we're not alone."
In other words, whenever Streep needs to cry
on screen, she simply remembers how important
it is for Meryl Streep to cry on screen, and
she gets the job done.
That kind of gumption just can't be taught,
so it's no wonder she's so many light-years
ahead of the rest.
Oprah Winfrey seems to be good at everything,
but when the TV mogul does occasionally dip
her toes into the waters of Hollywood to star
in a movie, it's not always easy for her.
In fact, Winfrey told Larry King that before
she earned an Academy Award nomination for
her work in The Color Purple, she felt like
a failure because she could only cry when
the cameras were pointed elsewhere during
production.
As soon as they were facing her, the tears
were nowhere to be found.
"So all night long I cried, because I couldn’t
cry."
Winfrey later revealed that before she began
working on Lee Daniels' The Butler, she decided
to bring in some help and learn how to fake
some of that raw emotion that came so easily
on her daytime talk show.
Winfrey said:
"Everybody thinks that I'm a good crier, an
easy crier.
I can cry if I'm in the moment and feeling
emotion, but as an actress, that was one of
my biggest fears.”
Thanks to the enlistment of an acting coach,
Winfrey said she figured out how to make herself
cry in just 20 minutes.
Now, that’s something to jump up and down
about.
The late, great Shirley Temple might have
been just a tiny tyke when she became a legend
of the early screen scene, but even then she
was a consummate professional.
In a 1999 interview the former child superstar
revealed her method for breaking out with
a wail on camera, saying:
"I guess I was an early method actress.
I would go to a quiet part of the soundstage
with my mother.
I wouldn't think of anything sad, I would
just make my mind a blank.
In a minute I could cry."
Temple did have one crying caveat, though.
The Hollywood legend said she didn’t like
to cry after lunch, because she was too content.
Who can be sad after chowing down on animal
crackers in their soup?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movie stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel, and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.